-We're about to play a game
called "What's Behind Me?"
My partner tonight
is the star of
"God's Favorite Idiot"
on Netflix
and host of HGTV's
"The Great Giveback."
Please give it up for the one
and only Melissa McCarthy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah. Oh, come on.
-Hello!
-They love you.
Come on now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you.
So good to see you.
-It's good to see you too.
-Here's how the game works.
Melissa and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us have seen before.
It could be people,
objects, anything.
Once the curtain opens up,
you have to pick up your card.
You have 45 seconds to try to
get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything you want
or use gestures.
You just can't say any of
the words on your card.
Okay, Melissa, you will be
guessing first.
So let's get into position.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-Oh, Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
They don't tell you
about that part.
-All of our budget went to this.
Alright.
Let's open the curtain
and see what is behind you.
Hmm.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no!
No!
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, alright, alright.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not a good sign!
-It's the undead.
-Uh, uh, zombie.
-Yes, and they are doing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They are doing --
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're doing a sexy type
of thing involving a pole.
-Oh.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, gosh. I can't say that.
Okay, sorry.
It's a --
-Pole dancing?
-Yes.
So it's that at a place where
you see a lot of fish tanks --
giant fish tanks.
-Aquarium.
-That's correct.
It a zombie pole-dancing
at an aquarium.
-Can I look?
-You can look at this.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I thought it was a picture.
-I was so -- I was so distracted
by what I saw.
I didn't know --
Well d-- Oh! Thank you.
Alright, okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Please close the curtain.
Can we close the curtain
so we don't have to see that?
Now, that is something --
-You don't see that every day.
[ Laughter ]
-And you also can't unsee it.
-No.
-Okay, now it's my turn
to guess.
Let's rotate.
♪♪
Now, you have the blue card.
When the curtains open,
the time will start.
Then you look at the blue card.
You can start talking.
But now let's see
what's behind me.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Alright. I'm not mad at it.
It's a -- It's a --
One of his names
could be Frosty.
-A snowman.
-Sure.
And he is partaking in a could
be tobacco ornate kind of --
-Smoking a bong?
-No.
-Vaping?
-Smoking a joint?
-No. You can kind of all share
from this.
-Oh, a hookah?
-Sure.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he's -- It's a certain --
You dress up in costumes
on this day.
-Oh, it's Halloween.
-Yes.
-It's a snowman smoking a hookah
on Halloween.
-Yes.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is unbelievable.
-I like him.
-That's not bad.
That should be a T-shirt maybe.
Or the new mascot to
"The Tonight Show."
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like I dated that guy.
Like, for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, now, it's your turn
to guess.
-Okay.
-Let's rotate.
-It's always a little "oh."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, let's see what is
behind you.
Let's see what's behind you.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-It's two video game characters
that are very famous.
They're Italian plumbers.
-Oh, Mario and his pal?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Mario and --
-He has a green hat.
In England if you go to the
bathroom, you go to the --
-Loo. Louis.
-Mario and --
-Louie.
[ Laughter ]
-They're at an event where
two people join in matrimony.
-A wedding.
-Yes, and they're playing music.
[ Applause ]
-They're playing music.
They're musicians?
-No, but they're connected to
speakers.
-D--
Deejay?
-Yes, that is correct!
It's Super Mario and Luigi.
-Luigi!
-Luigi, deejaying a wedding.
There they are.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very good.
-That's exactly right.
Oh, yeah.
-That seems -- Oh!
-They're really into it.
-I'm over the edge.
-I don't know who is
into it more, Mario or Luigi.
But they're looking at each
other they're like both
scratching each other's...
♪♪
Alright, that's good.
I've had enough.
Thank you very much.
I think we've had --
That was not bad.
-In like four hours
and like many drinks later,
I would love for that to open up
and be like, "Oh, God."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, it is the final round.
-Yes.
-Let's rotate the stage.
♪♪
♪ Oh, yeah, rotate the stage ♪
Now, let's see what's
behind me.
Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, um...
He's got a need for speed.
-Tom Cruise?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maverick.
-He's doing -- Um, it's
a relaxation thing people
do in the park,
and it's simultaneous.
-Tai Chi.
-Tai Chi, sure.
And he's doing it not on Earth,
but up --
-On the moon?
-Well, where is the moon?
-He's in space.
-He's in space!
-Tom Cruise in space
doing Tai Chi.
[ Dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Oh, look at three Tom Cruises
in space doing Tai Chi.
That is Melissa McCarthy,
everybody.